[Music]
dns is a critical part of your
infrastructure
i'm eric gray from vmware and in this
video you'll learn how to create dns
profiles and configure conditional
forwarding so you can connect
authenticate and migrate throughout your
multi-cloud environment
each google cloud vmware engine
deployment includes a pair of dns
servers that provide name resolution for
management components within the private
cloud
if you need to integrate your on-prem
and vmware engine environments you can
set up a dns profile that will forward
requests according to domain name
name resolution is a dependency for
capabilities such as vmware hcx
migration and active directory
authentication
when you create a dns profile you can
add one or more domains or subdomains in
the corresponding authoritative servers
each private cloud can have one dns
profile attached but you can add
multiple domains or subdomains to meet
your business requirements
workload vms can either point to your
existing centralized dns servers or they
can use the integrated servers directly
when using the built-in dns servers
proper profile configuration ensures
that the names outside of the private
cloud will resolve workloads can also
resolve the addresses of vmware engine
management components for configuration
or automation use cases
if you need to connect to the vsphere
nsx or hcx management interfaces from
your on-prem networks you can set up
conditional forwarding on your existing
enterprise infrastructure services
simply add a new forwarder for the
unique gve.goog subdomain associated
with your private cloud and supply the
ip addresses of the built-in dns servers
the configurations we just covered
enable name resolution from two
perspectives management components of
vmware engine can connect to on-prem
resources and clients outside the
private cloud can resolve and connect to
interfaces such as the vsphere client
now that you know how to configure dns
in your google cloud vmware engine
private cloud check out the next video
in this series to learn about
configuring active directory
authentication for vsphere admins
to learn more about google cloud vmware
engine visit our site at
cloud.google.com
vmware dash engine
[Music]
you